hall of fame thursday so we wanted to
invite our good friend charles barkley
to join us as well because i go to the
well every time marshall you know i have
like a i have a routine i gotta go to
charles i gotta go to you i gotta go to
shaq and i gotta go to jerry west but
we're your people you're my people hi
charles
what's up y'all hi honey how are you
i'm doing great i'm in cold cleveland
i'm getting ready for all-star weekend
but i am doing wonderful did you see
your crazy friend shaq in his video
getting on a plane in a full-length fur
coat yesterday that was ridiculous that
was funny
i did not see that i you know i don't
you know i don't do any social media
anything like that i was flying to
cleveland
and uh
i have not done anything i haven't
looked at any television since i got
here i'm actually getting ready for
march madnesses to be honest with you
trying to figure out who the top 10
teams are yeah
hey hey charles i i got to ask you about
this because it was it was just so funny
to me
um
to watch durant
dance around
not picking harden
come on man
how how funny was that i know that team
man let me tell you something
it's crazy
i'll get sick of talking about them i
don't know who i get more sick of
talking about
the the the nets or the lakers the
liquors stink and everybody still talks
about them every day like they
legitimate and they aren't they stink
but uh listen the nets james hearts had
enough he said like yo man i didn't sign
up for all this stupidity i'm gonna keep
it moving and but
it's gonna be much seat must see tv the
next
two to three months about
philly how that thing's gonna work out
in brooklyn it's going to be fun my
job's going to be fun once i get through
with march madness it's going to be
must-see to how what happened with those
two teams who who won the trade who won
the trade
uh brooklyn want to trade
[Music]
yeah brooklyn won the trade i mean they
get an all-star in ben simmons
they get steph curry who's one of the 10
best shooters i like drummond who's
already paying dividends
and listen when they get kd back
and kyrie for half the time
i mean they could be they could win this
thing now
i heard uh i heard silver
silver said to new york he he was like
listen
and i think this is this is good for
kyrie he said i don't understand if the
visiting team
if their players who are not vaccinated
can play why is there a double standard
for kyrie like that was for him to say
that was something
well it's interesting you know and i
really number one i think everybody
should get vaccinated uh
i implore everybody out there to get
vaccinated not just for yourself but the
people around you so i i implore
everybody to get vaccinated that being
said
it is interesting and quite stupid that
people who are not vaccinated
can play there except players who
actually play there
it's a really stupid interesting thing
uh
kyrie can stop all this stuff he just
got vaccinated and and we wouldn't be in
this situation but the rules are the
rules it's just a stupid rule i mean i'm
not and to be honest with you marsh i
didn't even know until yesterday
that that people who people could work
there
who who don't live there
can come there and work there without
being vaccinated i did not know that
until adam said it yesterday we were
actually talking about it last night and
it's just a stupid rule plain and simple
charles barkley joining us here on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line susie
shuster in for rich eisen marshall
fought with me all three hours charles i
want to just quickly go to this ben
simmons situation because i'd like to
know from your opinion
how can you miss this much time saying
it's from mental health
and then
seemingly show up happy move on and
start suiting up
it's it's a really hard message
it's not a hard message i listen uh
mental illness is a serious thing i hate
that he was using that as a scapegoat
because you got to understand some
number one i live in arizona
but i live in philadelphia during the
summer
uh and ben simmons never
said anything
about mental health until they stopped
paying him
he just said he hated the sixers he
didn't want to be around doc rivers and
joel embiid
that was happening all summer i heard it
every day
all summer
and then when he figured out like oh
y'all not gonna pay me
and then he's basically uh uh um um he
starts stuttering like i got a mental
health issue
ben simmons first of all anybody got
mental health has my support for support
but if ben simmons had said that
when everything first happened
i wouldn't have had any problem with it
but what he did was a serious issue
that in our society
he started using that
when
he uh realized he was not going to get
paid
and now all of a sudden
he went and saw dr phil
for like on one of those hour shows and
he's fixed now he's ready to play now he
said he just got to get in basketball
shape
and he probably gonna come back against
the sixers in a couple weeks
so it lets you know that
what he was really doing he just didn't
want to play in philly and all of a
sudden like i said he saw dr phil dr
phil cured him in an hour he gonna get
in basketball shape
and he would surprise me if he played as
soon as the all-star game was over
suzy this this is this is a it's a thing
now because
uh
if you're an analyst
you can't really comment on this it's
it's a it's it's challenging
um and and and there's no measuring
stick
to say if he is or is if he isn't
and you don't want to be on the wrong
side of it
um
it's it's like it's it's really dicey
and for charleston you know like it's
like hey we don't know we we can't say
we just know
nobody in philly has confirmed now
and and and i actually i heard stephen a
say this well
well maybe nobody in philly wants to
confirm
because if they did hear it and didn't
do anything about it now they're in
trouble so it's a it's it's like it's
one of those dicey things like
who's telling the truth and who's not
but the reality is
in today's society um
and
back when charles played and i played
you in order to play in the leagues you
had to be mentally tough
like you didn't you didn't get a you
didn't get a a timeout when you when you
were a little foggy because you had some
problems and and now it's looked that
different and and they evaluated
different the player that got through
this kind of stuff and continued to play
they were kind of revered
it was that was like a badge of honor
and it's different now and and we have
to we have to kind of take the back seat
to it and and just
say hey we don't know we because we
really don't
you know marsh it's it's such an
interesting time we're in as players and
in the world
but mental health is a serious issue
and i i was disappointed in being from
for this aspect
you're making 40 million dollars a year
and your team criticizes you because
you went on a seven game series you went
an entire seven games and didn't score
in the fourth quarter
which that's almost impossible
especially when you're a max player and
you're expected to be the second best
player on the team
and you have a layup and you think
you're going to get fouled because you
are not shooting good free throws
and you pass up a dunk because they're
going to follow you
like i say you went seven games in a
seven game series and never scored a
basket in the fourth quarter that's
impossible to do
i mean you get a steal or a breakaway or
a layup or a dunk
somewhere along the way but you didn't
score in seven games
and you're coaching some people
criticize you
and your first response is like
i'm not playing with you guys anymore
and the one thing i know about playing
basketball or any sport you got to want
to get better for yourself screw your
teammates your coaches
your family and your friends
i don't think you want to be great for
any of them you want to be great for
them but the number one person you
should want to be great at your sport is
for yourself
and listen i've never had the pleasure
of making 30 or 40 million dollars a
year
but
if i could make that much money and
somebody said hey you just got to get
better at basketball i said oh no not
only will i get better at basketball if
you want me to babysit your kids on the
weekend
and cut your grass i'll do that too
my first respon my first response is not
going to be
no no y'all can't criticize me
and then the thing that really sucks
about it
he's probably in a better situation now
than he was a week ago
so uh but that's the world we live in
today you know this is the
transportation transfer portal as they
call it now mars
we are in the transfer portal and all of
all
walks of sports now
and you know dog rivers charles barkley
is on his way pretty soon for a uh so we
say a couple days off in warmer weather
and he'll have some time to think about
this but we're talking about a coach who
is really good with young players who's
a dad
and the way that he's gonna now gonna
have to come out of this and i wonder
it'll be interesting to see if you're
right that new jersey came out on top
but
you know
what he said was a challenge to ben
simmons in my opinion ben simmons should
have reacted and instead it's just
it's almost like
and again i'd say this with a grain of
salt if it is a mental illness issue i'm
not criticizing nor judging but
i want to be better if someone calls me
out i want to show them that they're
wrong so if somebody says to me
i'm not sure i can win with you
i want to show them that they can
believe in me
and i you know i remember last time
sitting in the chair it was right after
simone biles had pulled back and people
were just
judging her and saying this is
ridiculous you should be
competing for americans she said i need
to feel good about myself
and i was very vociferous in saying back
off if she's got some issues she's
spinning a million times through the air
and could break her skull at any time so
back off all you fat ass is sitting on
your sofas at home
yeah well i think
i think it's a couple things i think
number one i think the problem we myself
included how would ben ben never said
anything about mental illness
until they stopped paying him
because that's one thing you can't prove
people's mental illness but if he ever
said that i mean it was a whole three to
five months
before he said anything
about mental illness he never said
anything over the summer
and then when they stopped paying him
that's when he claimed mental illness if
he got a mental issue i think we
wouldn't have said anything but to bring
it up later we have a problem with
listen i think marshall touched upon it
earlier uh
i don't know about simone bile i don't
know enough about gymnastics to be
honest which but i will say this
these guys
they want all this money
they want all the accolades to go with
being rich and famous
it's pressure
if you don't want no pressure you need
to get a nine to five like a normal
amazing person work nine to five
but if you're gonna be rich and famous
there's a tremendous amount of pressure
on you to perform
just like it was on me marshall
uh everybody who's ever played the game
and now it's probably even more because
of the money they make
so
uh i hope anybody got some mental
illness get some help
but the bottom line is
if you're gonna be rich and famous
and get and get paid millions of dollars
you're gonna be under pressure
plain and simple
and if you don't want that pressure
you can't be rich and famous
and you can't whine about it
and say
i don't want to do this and well then
you can't take these people's money
and that's the bottom line yeah if
you're famous you're gonna be on a
tremendous amount of pressure
and that's just goes with the territory
plain and simple
yeah charles i i want when i think about
it it's like um
uh
when
when ben simmons was in year one or two
and and he was i mean he wasn't shooting
well then and he was being criticized by
his coach
i'm i'm sure he was like hey we gotta
work on this
uh he couldn't figure out if he was
left-handed or right-handed at that
point in time
um
we didn't hear about
you know and i'm wondering is it is it
is it the pressure
once you get the money to perform
is it not the same pressure that got you
the money when you when you didn't have
like i haven't seen somebody without
money like a [ __ ] i haven't seen a
bench player say
yeah dawg i got bent a problem i haven't
seen it yet it's only high profile when
they're not performing how they supposed
to be
in sports that's the only time we're
hearing it we're not hearing it from
the backup
or or somebody that's like
in a in a g-league
they're not saying it
because here's the thing and and this is
what
if the if the team find out that you
have that issue you're probably not
getting paid
you're probably not
but if it's a real issue you should say
it's an issue regardless
and we should like really really
provide help
right regardless like if ben had this
issue did this issue just come because
you're making all this money and you're
not performing or was it something that
you had when you left lsu
and you just didn't say anything about
it because you wanted to you wanted to
max out
and like for simone like did you have
these issues before you became a
national star
and didn't say anything about it or
you know has it always been an issue
like we we don't know those things and
that's what it makes it dicey for people
to really understand it that
you
you did all the work
to garner to pay to be at this level and
now because you can't take the pressure
it's a it's a mental issue it's it's
hard it's hard and a lot of people just
don't subscribe to it because there's
people who who are busting your butt in
a nine to five making like you know 18
bucks an hour they would like to call in
and have a mental issue day but they
can't
and they don't get it
what do you think charles
well
listen it's a really tricky it is
subject nowadays
but i always say this
yo man everybody got stuff going on
everybody got stuff going on no matter
how
rich famous poor whatever white black
hispanic jewish asian everybody's got
crap going on
and if you need some help
ask somebody
i always tell people you're never alone
uh like there's always everybody's got
somebody like hey pick up the phone and
call somebody like yo i'm struggling
but like i say this uh i think we just
have to be really careful
but like say the only problem i've ever
had with being if ben hadn't said
anything about mental illness in the
beginning
i think we was like hey let's get this
guy some help but he didn't say anything
about mental illness
like i say until he stopped still like
oh he gonna they're gonna they're not
gonna pay me
and listen
he looks very healthy in the first
couple things i've seen of him since he
got traded to brooklyn
so now everything kind of makes me
believe what i believed all along
and like i said hey it's unfortunate
that he got his way
it's unfortunate i want to make that
clear
because
your
employer
has the right
to ask you to get better at your crap
suzy i think you said it earlier
and i said it earlier too like i wanted
to be great at basketball for myself
i know i had great family and friends
around me
the great teammates and and the
organization but the number one priority
for any job
is to be great for yourself
i mean i want it to be great
and
ben turned me and a lot of people off
when he got mad at the sixers
i like yo man you got to get better at
basketball
you know but when you're making 35
million dollars for the next three or
four years guaranteed there's nothing
it's not like the nfl they can cut you
if you ain't doing your job
ben knew he had a security blanket he
was gonna make 33 35 million dollars for
the next four years
and then and so now he but he's done to
me he's in a better situation
and i think that's unfortunate but hey
that's the game today when you make that
much money you have a lot of power i
mean look at james harden
this is the second team he's forced his
way out of he didn't like houston
uh after the denny's same thing in
brooklyn
but james makes 45 million dollars a
year
that's just the league we play in today
the players have all the power for now
because there's gonna be a lockout uh
just like there is in baseball there's
gonna be a lockout in football too
i've been saying for the last couple
years these owners are gonna get their
money back the next chance they get
them guys been paying all of us jocks
every single dime with nobody's in the
stands
and
they're gonna get their money back
baseball just have to go first
they're not gonna start on time when
it's time for football and basketball to
renegotiate
a lot of our guys are going to be
sitting at home too
but them owners going to get their money
back one way or the other
charles before we let you go i want to
know your thoughts on carla murray since
you are a
phoenix guy what are your thoughts
watching this quarterback play out all
this drama on instagram with the
cardinals
well you know i hate social media
yes we
listen
all those losers on social media they
have one thing in common they're not
working they just say they're talking
about other people they're just losers
okay so obviously i live in arizona
the first question callum murray got to
ask yourself
if the criticism fair
you can't overreact when you're a great
player
because great players
we're not all perfect
the first question you have to ask
yourself
are the coaches because whoever's
leaking this somebody's leaking it
the first thing you have to say soon
like we talking about you got to say to
yourself
i want to get better at a foot as a
football player
is what they're saying about me true
that's fair if
he has to look himself in the mirror he
can call it nonsense i saw his statement
he he's not in for this nonsense
but as a player
the first thing you have to ask yourself
and dr j taught me this
when i was first becoming a star
and there was a couple of things that
shook me up when i went from just being
a nobody to a star
that the game changes
and he says charles don't ever
overreact
look in the mirror and says it's the
criticism fair
and calamari has got to do that then if
the criticism is not fair
he can get mad
and do all that stupid stuff on social
media whatever i saw somebody i guess
they call it scribbling scribbling
something like that when you just erase
everybody which i don't even know what
that means
but the first thing you have to do as a
player
uh going we can go back to we're just
talking about ben simmons
are they right
and then and
of course in ben simmons situation we
they were 100 correct he needs to get
better
as a basketball player now to get back
to your original point i don't know kyle
murray i've never met him
uh
i would
be curious
i if i wanted to know anything about
that organization i'd probably call the
great lara fitzgerald even though he
didn't play this year he's been around
there the last couple years
and i'd ask him off the record about
calamari personally
but i don't know a lot of i i know what
i'm reading
but i don't know what's true truth
that's the key
you know all these internet people and
people voicing opinions that's just
stuff i read
on bleacher report
or espn shows me something like that but
i don't know what's true but i think the
first to get back to your original
question
callum murray has to ask himself
is the criticism fair
and then you can make an informed
decision but you have to look in the
mirror first and foremost and say
are the criticisms of me fair
charles berkeley that's why we call you
i like the straight shooting thanks pal
have fun in cleveland hey i appreciate
y'all y'all take care much love love you
pal
love you pam love you all too be safe
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here